[Música]
el humo cubre la capital de Sudán
imágenes de los combates y los ataques
aéreos antes del anuncio de un alto al
fuego la pausa de tres días en los
combates acordada entre el ejército
sudanés y los paramilitares de las
fuerzas de apoyo rápido contó con la
mediación de Arabia Saudita y Estados
Unidos desde que estalló el conflicto
varios alto al fuego se han desmoronado
rápidamente el secretario de estado
estadounidense instó ambas partes a
mantener La tregua en esta ocasión el
pueblo sudanés no renuncia a sus
aspiraciones de un futuro seguro libre y
democrático y Nosotros tampoco lo
haremos un tercio de la población de
Sudán necesitaba ayuda antes del
conflicto ahora la situación se agrava
por la escasez de alimentos agua
electricidad y medicinas el centro de
diálisis es el único de jartum que sigue
funcionando estamos muy cansados
Esperamos que Dios ayude al país y lo
proteja queremos que el estado encuentre
una solución para la gente que necesita
hospitales
decenas de miles de lugareños han unido
a los vecinos Egipto chat y Sudán del
sur
en pisar Mohamed el Hash logró cruzar la
frontera hacia Egipto con su marido y
tres hijos
el momento más duro es pensar en
abandonar tu país mientras Oyes los
sonidos de las explosiones y los
disparos
hace tres años el principal partido
civil de Sudán fue derrocado por los dos
generales que ahora se están enfrentando
el partido ha acogido con satisfacción
el alto al fuego y Espera que esto ayude
a entablar negociaciones para resolver
el conflicto la ONU ha advertido que una
eventual guerra en Sudán supondría un
riesgo para toda la región